There are actually two net neutralities.
There's the original idea, and then
there's what it's morphed into. The
original idea, which a lot of people
agreed with, is that customers should be
allowed to do what they want to when
they're using Internet services: Connect
whatever equipment they want to; get to
whatever services are out there.
And, you stop to think about it, it makes a
lot of sense. Would you really want
someone saying you can't use Netflix on
your broadband connection? Or you can't
use that iPhone because I'm fighting
with Apple over something? But what it
has morphed into is government
restrictions on what customers can get.
And it's not done by saying, "Well,
customers are not allowed to buy this or
buy that". Instead it's saying broadband
providers cannot provide those services
to customers.
One of the motivations for net
neutrality was to keep Internet service
providers from throttling traffic. But we
have consumer protection. The Federal
Trade Commission has the responsibility
for addressing issues where consumers
are told
"I'm giving you this," but in reality I'm
doing something else.